Saudi experience right every accent
I'm anywhere
oh you don't this is a story about Saudi
people not Saudi politics
driving in Saudi Arabia it wasn't
allowed until well last summer for a
woman so today I'm gonna take us through
the streets of Riyadh with a Saudi woman
who is going to show us what it's like
to drive as women in Saudi Arabia hello
I'm here eat there either yeah Peter
doesn't you look for like a professional
behind the wheel already for months so
this this started like it was last
summer right yeah when you I guess at
first people are becoming very very
excited and everyone just wanted to get
the license
after that when we really like got all
the license the people are starting to
buy cars and everything
it becomes very like the norm right
right
even the loans for the cars were very
flexible for our girls the loans were
flexible yeah so it was actually it was
less money for a woman to buy a car than
a minute yeah I think because I've got
insurance things as well because they
don't talk about so much accident said
as guys do like this car for example
have you crashed but it wasn't my fault
really I would think that though you
know if you have all these new drivers
that have less experience maybe and then
their insurance rates would be higher
who's the opposite because men probably
tried more aggressively aggressively but
you drive pretty fast actually Toria
well tonight it's Friday today so
there's like no no traffic yeah this is
like an exciting time for me right for
young Saudis I would think yeah
yeah because I know I mean I have no
idea what's going on I've been here two
days right but I'm like my so much
information in my head and they can't
imagine
it's like like I honestly saw a video
that was meat made this year that said
if you if you get caught and taking
videos or photos in public you will go
to prison for one year and get 100
lashes this is what was online we have
this new rules of everything like before
we started driving I said you know
because they don't want people to film
women driving
oh so before yes okay but now it's okay
no but still you can't
right right the day you find out that
women are allowed to drive
[Music]
we were like we didn't believe it as far
as like is it actually as a treat as
it's finally are we going to drive are
you sure and then we started dancing and
singing and everything and the date
except for women driving we were all out
and we were waiting like at 12 o'clock
yes where are you women and they starts
driving and it was like very nice
everyone was waving at them and they
were waving back and having fun yeah
what percentage of women are out here on
the roads you think he of India yeah
it's it's very high I would say 80 70 80
percent of women drive yes where are you
taking this to I have not had sunny food
you will hear about men rights very soon
you're saying women get jobs easier than
men yes because if you have one woman
it's like you have been to men
company and they work harder it was like
they have like points they have to get
so each woman equals human this is the
coolest parking garage ever seen I've
never seen a prank
very nice place you thought okay
[Music]
is this one of your favorite restaurants
okay cool
districts okay-y there any jobs woman
cannot do
right
you're you're a lawyer in the startup
space
Wow Salaam alaikum
you're looking so good I'm trying you
too brother thank you how are you good
good good good
so are these concerts that's new here
right it's new like in the last one or
two years you one year it's the
offseason okay Ali how long have you
guys been friends one year I think one
year how did you meet your mutual
friends around okay there is about Chile
concerned if you know I'm the about
Chile
yeah yeah we make that you can't see the
carnival every day this is the main okay
it takes
tomato onion and everything makes up
family were kapda yes chicken liver okay
the maintenance and
it's very similar rhythm what is food
it looks like soup what do the men think
about women driving in general
oh we have one here so I'm kind of dope
you guys get along yeah she's a good
driver though yes she's good who drives
faster we have faster and they drive
dangerous whoa
did you know their insurance is cheaper
because they have less accidents it's
true facts we follow the rules
we differently than you you will know
although the main road we follow our
rules
that's something's a little weird here
I'm the one dressing like the
traditional sorry God first up Saudi
Arabia and the prison Saudi Arabia and
the future cetera it's completely
there's big gaps between them right
you'll you'll look like simple Torah
different people defend everything so
the new the new Saudi Arabia I will
apply it's exciting yeah be connection
with the world without lose your culture
without us result without choose what
you want to God that's the tough part I
think nowadays they're asking for yoga
instructor yeah so I wouldn't I wouldn't
say companies here are asking for yoga
instructors don't you do this type of
awareness we must really away from like
being on a wheel
what do you mean what do you mean by a
wheel being like the machines and really
separate ourselves from
from the culture just be
sell ourself to the system you know
and the system here is
aware of that
and you're aware of that and how old are
you if you don't mind me asking that's
amazing it's amazing wisdom to have a 25
nice place that was like a modern Saudi
experience right
but like professional and this is what
is this place it was interesting you and
Ali were in disagreement about driving
these styles yeah
but you think there is a difference in
the genders right what you're saying yes
and I don't think we think difference
means having the upper hand for men no
that's totally it's not
what are you saying
saying we are different we should
appreciate differences and embrace them
in a very respectful
[Music]
we don't deny them
anointings them
oh one thing I had a question of you
know the woman that are in full cover
right
do you think they all want to be in full
cover or someone to me and like what did
it can you tell me like I can't
interview that I can't talk to that
person obviously so
two hours no many people are ready
there are many they don't know what they
want like anything in general
they would choose the most haunted
of course in university they wouldn't
choose a proper job they would choose
things like that
so they doesn't really make their own
choices in general life
it's not like for one basically
so it depends upon the woman some women
prefer to be fully covered by their own
individual choice and other people are
just doing what society says and then
others I'm sure are doing because that's
what their husband really do you think
the the Saudi woman are very strong
there's like a very strong character and
personality yes
I mean
in the middle of the desert what do you
expect
other than strong personalities right
you have to have a strong
that's community with environments like
when you look to the history yeah but
that said thank you so much either you
were awesome great driving experience
cool have a nice day bye bye thank you
that's it guys day driving with a local
Saudi woman it's an exciting time here
we could feel the excitement out of
these guys like so much rapid change so
many new freedoms and it's palpable you
can feel it here so hope you like that
until next one
you